وصل رئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون الى
بكين في زياره الى الصين ترافقه فيها
رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبي ارسل كما يرافقه
عدد كبير من الوزراء ورجال الاعمال ورؤساء
الشركات الذين سيوقع بعضهم بعضهم عقودا مع
شركات صينيه وستكون الحرب في اوكرانيا في
صلب المحادثات التي سيجيها ماكرون مع
المسؤولين الصينيين
الفرنسي والامريكي الليله الماضيه ان
بايدن عربا عن رغبتهم المشتركه في اشراك
الصين في جهود تسريع انهاء الحرب في
اوكرانيا
وهذه الصور
كنا نتابع سنه معكم صوره مباشره لرئيس
الفرنسي لكن ربما نعود اليها في سياق هذه
النشره عند مشاهدينا الان ينضم الينا من
بكين الصحفي نادر اهلا بك سيد نادر معنا
في هذه النشره بدايه هذه الزياره زياره
الرئيس الفرنسي الى الصين البدعوه من
الرئيس الصيني ما الذي ترغب بكين في
تحقيقه من هذه الزياره
[موسيقى]